Today we're going to dig into a
really powerful argument about
our cities and the money that
makes them run.
The main idea is pretty simple,
but it's kind of a bombshell.
The entire game has changed, all
because money figured out how to
move.
So let's kick things off with a
belief that you see all over the
place, especially online.
It's the idea that when you get
down to it, wealthy people don't
really have a choice about
taxes.
You know that their money is
stuck in one place, so they just
have to pay whatever the
government asks.
But is that actually true
anymore?
And this comment right here,
this is from a real social media
thread, and it just perfectly
captures that skepticism.
It's basically a dare, right?
The assumption is, come on, rich
people don't actually pack up
and move just to dodge taxes.
Well, the author of the piece
we're looking at saw this and
had a few thoughts.
And here's the author's answer
right off the bat.
Remember Facebook's Co founder?
Yeah, he moved to Singapore.
The famous French actor Jerrod
Depardio, He literally fled to
Belgium and then Russia to
protest high taxes.
And we've all seen the stories
about people leaving California
for Austin and Miami or New
Yorkers heading for the suburbs.
The examples are, well, they're
everywhere once you start
looking for them.
This brings us to the most
important point of the whole
argument.
The idea that your zip code is
some kind of permanent binding
contract is just old thinking.
For high earners, choosing where
to live is now a financial
decision.
And it's a decision they can and
absolutely do rethink every
single year when it's time to
file their taxes.
To really get why this is such a
huge deal now, we've got to take
a step back in time, back to an
era when things were completely
different, a time when capital
couldn't just pack its bags and
leave town.
The author uses this fantastic
metaphor.
Money used to be heavy.
Think about it.
It was physically tied to the
ground.
It was massive steel mills.
It was railroad tracks.
It was giant bank vaults filled
with actual cash and gold.
You couldn't just move a
Rockefeller sized fortune to
another country overnight.
It was literally locked in place
by tons of concrete and steel.
And what was the result of all
that heavy money?
Well, because capital was
basically trapped, governments
had an incredible amount of
power.
They could set-top marginal tax
rates at over 90%.
They could do that because they
knew there was simply nowhere
for that money to run.
And this wasn't just a quick
thing either.
We're talking about decades from
funding World War 2 all the way
through the Great Society
programs in the 60s.
This super high tax environment
was just normal.
It was a completely different
economic universe, and it was
all built on the fact that
wealth couldn't move.
But then everything changed.
That old world of heavy money
just kind of dissolved.
Capital became something else.
It became weightless, almost
like vapor.
This slide really lays out the
huge shift.
You know, we went from capital
that was bound to one place to
capital that's instantly mobile,
from wealth that was trapped by
physical stuff to wealth that
moves with the click of a mouse.
And maybe the most important
change of all, taxation went
from being a form of coercion,
basically a demand, to a form of
courtship, like an invitation.
So how did this all happen?
The author argues it was
basically a perfect storm.
You had deregulation in the 80s
that opened up the financial
floodgates.
You had new tech like fiber
optic cables that made billion
dollar transfers happen in a
split second.
Even physical things got more
mobile thanks to global
container shipping.
And on top of all that, you had
these incredibly complex
financial tools like trusts and
shell companies that make wealth
almost impossible to pin down.
OK, so this new reality of
vaporous money, it creates a
massive, massive problem for
cities because cities need a
stable tax base to actually
function, and suddenly that base
can just disappear.
Here's another really powerful
analogy the author uses.
Think of a city's tax base as
frogs in a pan of water.
If you raise the temperature
slowly, they might just sit
there.
But if you turn up the heat too
fast with a sudden new tax or
big drop in quality of life,
those frogs are going to jump
right out and find a cooler pan.
And this is exactly how that
frog's leap plays out in the
real world.
The author describes this
totally predictable cycle.
First, a city proposes a big tax
hike.
The high earners feel the water
getting hot, and they start
making panicked calls to real
estate agents in Florida or
Texas.
Then they leave.
And what happens next?
The city, facing a huge budget
hole, has to cool the water back
down, offering tax breaks and
other incentives to try and get
them to come back.
Now, it's really important to
understand who these frogs are.
The author isn't just talking
about a handful of billionaires.
They actually coin this amazing
term, the Princess and the P
class.
These are high earning
professionals, think doctors,
lawyers, software engineers.
They're super sensitive to these
changes because unlike
billionaires, they can't change
the rules where they live.
But they absolutely have the
money to just move.
And this chart really shows you
why that group matters so much.
The author calls them the
invisible scaffolding holding up
a city's budget.
While billionaires get all the
media attention.
It's this huge group of
professionals that provides most
of the tax revenue for
everything.
Schools, transit, public
services.
So when they leave, the whole
structure starts to shake.
What you end up with is this
constant high stakes game of
chicken.
A city threatens to raise taxes
and its most mobile, highest
earning residents threaten to
walk.
And in this new world of
vaporous, weightless wealth, the
author argues that the city is
almost always the one that has
to swear first.
So this brings us to the
author's really startling
conclusion about the new laws of
physics that govern our cities.
It's not about left wing or
right wing politics anymore.
It's about something much more
fundamental, something like
gravity.
The entire dynamic has been
turned on its head.
In the past, taxation was
coercion.
The city's stance was pay your
tribute.
Now it's courtship.
The city's stance is please,
please build here.
And the best example of this is
that whole Amazon HQ 2 search,
that massive beauty contest
where cities all over the
country were falling over
themselves, offering billions in
tax breaks just to woo one
company.
And you see this courtship
everywhere, right?
Cities are constantly chasing
these huge, flashy projects.
A gleaming new stadium and
innovation corridor, a bid for
the Olympics.
According to the author, these
projects aren't just about civic
pride.
They're basically coded
invitations designed to signal
to mobile capital, hey, we're
business friendly.
Come here.
And that leaves us with this
final pretty haunting question
from the author.
We're living in an age of
portable money, which also means
portable loyalty.
O if the people with the
resources can always just jump
to a cooler pan, what happens to
our cities?
And more imortantly, what does
that mean for the people who are
left behind?
It's a really powerful thought
to end on.